hi this is Jerry Rice welcome to
football support auntie so what is the
best position to play a football really
we talk about why receivers that's the
most exciting one because you get a
chance to catch the football and score a
touchdown
okay Guapo goat is in the narrow rail
talks about the double moves of Thomas
but I remember seeing Randy Moss Jerry
Rice doing those routes in one move and
being open what is better it really
depends on the situation because you
have to set the defensive back up so
sometimes it takes double moves
sometimes you just got to you know just
use that one move and try to get out of
your route as quickly as possible let me
show you how that's done the double move
and a single move I use the double move
when I wanted to just buy a little bit
more time for the quarterback first off
my first move would be here to push him
more it down inside now defensive back
they're known to always react to second
moves and they feel like once you do
that second move now they have you in a
position where they can cover you so
let's move here now he's gonna jump all
over this that that's my second move and
now I just slice right back down inside
and I pretty much got a area where the
quarterback and deliver the football if
I do it in one move one single move in
the guy's position inside of me I can't
step this way because he's still gonna
be down inside of me so I got to attack
him moving so I'm gonna go at him and
try to get positioned then lean on him a
little bit and get inside and make the
catch Alex Smith is there anything
prettier than a perfectly executed post
route for a touchdown
no there's nothing prettier because the
execution has to be just right and when
I'm running the post route I want to
step right on the defensive back toes
before I go to the post and once I close
that gap I know I'm in a position where
I could make the catch and score the
touchdown
rich homie step super random but what's
the black stuff football players put
under their eyes and why do they use it
it blares out the Sun just a little bit
if the ball is in a position up in the
air
you can focus in on in just a little bit
more but I always did it just because I
thought it was cool
Breathitt Meyers can you explain why
crossing the plain rules are different
for a runner than a wide receiver the
rules are a little bit different between
a running back and a wide receiver the
second a running back crosses the
goal-line are if he's making an effort
to stick the ball off out and score a
touchdown and breaks the plane and he
loses control of the ball it's a
touchdown
but what for why receiver is totally
different the new rule states that we
have to have complete control of the
ball all the time okay Kay wait they
stop playing football when is rainy so
wimpy you know in real football they
play in the rain and even in the snow
the only thing that's gonna stop a
football game is lightning and thunder
Justin how did Jerry Rice play until he
was 42 that's just crazy that is crazy
you know to play for such a long time
but I think I love the game of football
and I had conditioned my body in a way
that I could play for a long time the
lifespan of football players about four
years I played for a long long time and
I wish I could have played on till I was
15 I've never heard of a wide receiver
giving himself up on a play isn't that
reserved for quarterbacks if you have to
give yourself up as a quarterback and go
down just like a quarterback you have to
do that to stay safe on the football
field
Andrew McLaughlin if you have a wide
receiver jam into the inside what does
your brain tell you to do if you if you
have a wide receiver that's inside of
you I really want to keep him inside so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give them a
step inside to make him go further
inside because now I'm opening up more
room on the boundary for the quarterback
to delivered football and I'm going to
show you how to do that right now
if a defensive back is jammed inside my
thing is now I have to be an actor I got
to get get him off his position to make
him feel uncomfortable so it's more
about activity if he's inside like that
I want to go here first and if I do that
he's gonna attack me now
get back down inside so it'd be more
like this almost sticking down inside
here here back she is Queen I wonder do
football players practice how they're
going to celebrate their touchdowns you
know I I never practice a celebration
you have to think about everything that
goes into preparation during a week what
they have to work on once they score a
touchdown but I'm not totally against it
Eleonora Penna what did browns have to
do to satisfy the Rooney rule the Rooney
rule it gives black coaches an
opportunity to go in and showcase what
they are capable of doing also as a head
coach it was something that needed to be
done and it's just only gonna help those
like coaches get an equal opportunity
just like everyone else H can girls play
football yes they can and I think it is
great seeing them out there so I
strongly support it 100%
Zachary could football be obsolete in 50
years
if technological advancements aren't
made to better protect players
I don't think football is gonna go away
fans love seeing these ladi Gators go
out there and do battle Rob win-win does
old age a way experience in football
should a force retirement age be
introduced I think when your body can't
sustain expectations of what you used to
do on the football field I think it's
time for you to walk away but it's a
really tough decision you have to do a
lot of soul-searching but you know if
you can't sustain what you used to do on
the football field it's time to walk
away Evan F Fredo who is the best wide
receiver of all time I don't know that's
kind of hard to say for me I just love
playing the game it is great for my fans
to say I was the greatest but you know
you'll never hear me say that Alex
Ferguson do you think college football
players should be paid yes they're
generating so much money for those
schools and you know I think it's only
fair that these college players should
be you know compensated for it Jordan
all break what is the most realistic
have to say Rudy that was my movie that
was the movie that inspired me to go out
and be exceptional in the football
fields
Jason gross what is the best song a
stadium can't play to kick off a
football game I don't have a favorite
but it has to be something really upbeat
something to get my juices going on the
football field but just the energy from
the fans and being in that stadium I'm
ready to go and Smith what type of
exercise weightlifting exercises ready a
player for football at the highest level
football it's a game of speed so it's
all about track work being able to run
get routes on the football field being
able to catch the football this is how
you do that I have been known to also do
triple moves the triple move consists of
this double go here here come back I
called it the right at a time
hey thanks for watching I'm Jerry Rice
and this was football support